I'm Gina Poindexter from recent Columbia
Graduate visual arts major and I've been
working in the conservation lab since
junior year as a senior we did a senior
thesis class in which we got studio
space and we got to work on a project of
our choice it ended up revolving around
some books that i made i think it was
largely informed by my exposure to books
in the library i ended up making a
series of four books and around this
correspondence letter writing project
that i did i think that being an avid
reader growing up and things like that
i'd always kind of understood the book
as like an intellectual device or some
kind of transmission of information but
making my own kind of really got me to
think about the book as a thing or as an
object and i think that being able to
make my own opened up this world of
opportunity and realizing that there
were creative places to take it and ways
to kind of make it your own or there's
so much more to explore especially as
something you could you could do with
your hands instead of something that you
could just read what working here
allowed me to see largely was just the
larger picture of colombia's this kind
of infinite resource or just like being
exposed to like the Incan a Beulah and
seeing books from centuries and
centuries ago even if it's just in the
capacity of like measuring them and
holding them they just start to feel so
precious and it's kind of an intense
experience to be around that kind of
history and to know that it's available
to us as students I was able to go to my
supervisor and tell her that I was
thinking about doing this project for a
year abroad and that I wanted it to be
something with bookmaking and
immediately she'd sent an email to the
head of the rare books and manuscripts
library and I was able to go up there
and just get exposed again to just
different kinds of books beyond the
classic binding structure that you would
need for a class or need to write a
paper and it was kind of again just like
this surge of inspiration realizing that
there
are people who are doing like novel
revolutionary things still with just
these fundamental tools to quote
professor Romo the book is the thing he
is an artist that I respect a lot and he
does all of his work in books he doesn't
have a gallery and the reason is because
they're portable and they're accessible
and usually affordable more affordable
than a print you would buy off of a
gallery wall and so I think that in
terms of my art it's also been a really
neat realization for me that it's such a
good way to communicate at such a good
way such a good conduit for whatever
message I'm trying to send and I love
that you can handle it and it feels
personal another job I had this year was
a position of an extracurricular art
instructor at a high school in Midtown
the highlight was that I got to kind of
revamp the sketchbook making bookbinding
demo that I'd gotten here at Columbia in
a studio art classroom and kind of
channel that into a remedial school in
Midtown of kids from all five boroughs
who are being exposed to the same thing
that I received you know with a columbia
education and i think that the
experience of mine of making my own book
kind of reading or my relationship with
books totally i could see that happening
with some of these kids to when you
realize that something you really only
think is as having a utility or some
kind of function you realize that you
can produce it on your own it's like you
know then you start thinking i could
write books too and now i'm going to
ghana to research grief and mourning and
funeral practices which are actually
less morbid than they are here that it's
a more celebratory culture i'm hoping to
make a series of books containing prints
that i've made through the experience
probably woodcuts
just because that's going to be the raw
material that's available to me over
there but i think that considering this
new like the book is the same kind of
mentality that i was able to develop
over the senior year i'm really looking
forward to you know being on my own and
try with i have no idea what tools will
be available to me and trying to
replicate and use all that I've learned
here to to make something that's going
to make a lasting impression on some
people